الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيم واعتدل استو سو الصف سد
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اقترب
للناس حسابهم وهم في غفله
معرضون ما ياتيهم من ذكر من ربهم محدث الا
استمعوه وهم يلعبون
لاهيه
قلوبهم واسروا النجوى الذين ظلموا هل هذا
الا بشر
مثلكم افتاتون السحر وانتم
تبصرون قال ربي يعلم القول في
السماء والارض وهو السميع العليم بل قالوا
اضغاث احل من بل افتراه بل هو شاعر فليات
بايه كما ارسل
الاولون ما امنت قبلهم من قريه
اهلكناها افهم
يؤمنون وما ارسلنا قبلك الا رجالا نوحي
اليهم فاسالوا اهل الذكر ان كنتم لا
تعلمون وما جعلناهم جسدا لا ياكلون الطعام
وما كانوا
خالدين ثم
صدقناهم الوعد
فانجيناكم
فانجيناهم ومن
نشاء
فانجيناهم ومن نشاء
واهلكنا المسرفين
لقد انزلنا اليكم كتابا فيه
ذكركم افلا
تعقلون وكم قصمنا من قريه كانت
ظالمه
وانشان بعدها قوما
اخرين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وكم من قريه كانت ظالمه
فاهلكناهم قصمنا من قريه كانت ظالمه
وانشان بعدها قوما
اخرين فلما احسوا باسنا اذا هم منها
يركضون لا ترك ضو لا تركضوا وارجعوا الى
ما اترفتم فيه
ومساكنكم لعلكم
تسالون قالوا يا ويلنا انا كنا
ظالمين فما زالت تلك دعواهم حتى جعلناهم
حصيدا
خامدين وما خلقنا
السماء والارض ما بينهما
لاعبين لو اردنا ان نتخذ لهو
لاتخذناه من
لدنا
لاتخذناه من لدنا ان كنا
فاعلين بل نقذف بالحق على الباطل فيدمغه
فاذا هو
زاهق ولكم الويل مما
تصفون وله من في السماوات والارض ومن
عنده ومن
عنده لا
يستكبرون عن عبادته ولا
يستحسرون يسبحون الليل
والنهار
يسبحون الليل والنهار
لا
يفترون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله ا الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
‏okay
[Silence]
السكات
founds pleasing
frs find
[Silence]
الله
‏fathered
was the original heart attacks ands but
last night when i day ag he was
transfering they
transcal here
شاك الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل
استوم الله اكبر
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وله من في السماوات والارض ومن عنده لا
يستكبرون عن عبادته ولا
يستحسرون يسبحون الليل والنهار لا يفترون
ام اتخذوا الهه من الارض ام اتخذوا الهه
من الارض هم
ينشرون ام اتخذوا الهه من الارض هم
ينشرون لو كان فيهما الهه الا الله
لفسدتا فسبحان الله رب العرش عما
يصفون لا يسال عما يفعل وهم يسالون ام
اتخذوا من دونه الهه قل هاتوا
برهانكم هذا ذكر من معي وذ من قبلي بل
اكثرهم لا يعلمون الحق فهم معرضون وما
ارسلنا من قبلك من رسول الا نوحي
اليه الا نوحي اليه انه لا اله الا انا
فاعبدون وقالوا اتخذ الرحمن
ولدا
سبحانه بل عبا
مكرمون لا يسبقونه بالقول وهم بامره
يعملون يعلم ما بين ايديهم وما
خلفهم ولا يشفعون الا لمن ارتضى وهم من
خشيته مشفقون ومن يقل منهم اني اله من
دونه فذلك نجزيه جهنم
كذلك نجزي
الظالمين اولم ير الذين كفروا ان السماوات
والارض كانتا رتقا ففتقناهما
وجعلنا من
الماء كل شيء حي افلا
يؤمنون وجعلنا في الارض رواسي ان تميد بهم
وجعل
وجعلنا فيها فجاجا سبلا لعلهم يهتدون
وجعلنا
السماء
سقفا
محفوظا
وهم وهم عن اياتها
معرضون وهو الذي جعل الليل
والنهار والشمس
والقمر وهو الذي خلق والليل والنهار
والشمس
والقمر كل في فلك
يسبحون وما
جعلنا وما جعلنا لبشر من قبلك الخلد افئ
مت فهم
الخالدون كل نفس
ذائقه الموت
ونبلوكم بالشر والخير فتنه والينا
ترجعون واذا راك الذين كفروا ان
يتخذونك الا
هزوا اهذا الذي يذكر الهتكم وهم بذكر
الرحمن هم
كافرون خلق
الانسان من عجل ساريكم اياتي فلا
تستعجلون ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين لو يعلم الذين كفروا حين لا يكفون
عن وجوههم النار ولا عن
ظهورهم ولا هم
ينصرون بل تاتيهم
بغته فتبهتهم
فتبهتهم فلا
يستطيعون ردها ولا هم
ينظرون ولقد استهزئ برسل من قبلك فحاق
بالذين سخروا
منهم فحاق بالذين سخروا منهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون قل من
يكلؤكم بالليل وال النهار من
الرحمن بل هم عن ذكر ربهم
معرضون ام لهم
الهه من ام لهم الهه تمنعهم من
دوننا لا
يستطيعون نصر انفسهم ولا هم منا
يسحبون بل متعنا هؤلاء
واباءهم حتى طال عليهم
العمر افلا يرون انا ناتي الارض
ننقصها من
اطرافها افهم
الغالبون قل انما
انذركم بالوحي ولا يسمع الصم
الدعاء اذا ما ينذر
ولئن مستهم نفحه من عذاب
ربك ولئن مستهم نفحه من عذاب ربك
ليقولن
ليقولن يا ويلنا انا
كنا
ظالمين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ونضع الموازين القسط ليوم
القيامه فلا تظلم نفس شيئا وان كان مثقال
حبه من خردل اتينا بها وكفى بنا
حاسبين ولقد اتينا موسى وهارون القران
وضياء وذكرا
للمتقين ولقد اتينا موسى وهارون الفرقان
للمتقين الذين يخشون ربهم بالغيب وهم من
الساعه مشفقون
وهذا ذكر مبارك
انزلناه
افانتم له
منكرون ولقد اتينا ابراهيم رشده من قبل
وكنا به
عالمين اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما هذه
التماثيل التي انتم لها
عاكفون قالوا وجدنا
اباءنا لها
عابدين قال لقد كنتم انتم
واباؤكم في ضلال
مبين قالوا اجئتنا بالحق ام انت من
اللاعبين قال بل ربكم رب السماوات والارض
الذي
فطرهن وانا على ذلك ك من
الشاهدين وت الله
لاكيدن
اصنامكم بعد ان تولوا
مدبرين فجعلهم جذاذا الا كبيرا لهم لعلهم
اليه
يرجعون قالوا من فعل هذا بالهتنا
انه لمن
الظالمين قالوا سمعنا فتي
يذكرهم يقال له
ابراهيم قالوا فاتوا به على اعين الناس
لعلهم
يشهدون قالوا انت فعلت هذا بالهتنا يا
ابراهيم قال بل فعله كبيرهم
هذا فاسالوه ان كانوا ينطقون
فرجعوا الى
انفسهم فقالوا انكم انتم
الظالمون ثم نكسوا على
رؤوسهم لقد علمت ما
هؤلاء
ينطقون قال
افتعال ينفعكم شيئا ولا يضركم
اف لكم ولما تعبدون من دون الله افلا
تعقلون قالوا حرقوه وانصروا الهتكم ان
كنتم
فاعلين قلنا يا نار كوني بردا وسلاما على
ابراهيم وارادوا به كيدا
فجعلناهم
الاخسرين ونجيناه ولوطا الى الارض التي
باركنا فيها
للعالمين ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب
نافله
وكلا جعلنا
صالحين و
وجعلناهم
ائمه يهدون بامرنا واوحينا
اليهم واوحينا اليهم فعل الخيرات واقام
الصلاه
وايتاء
الزكاه وكانوا لنا
عابدين الله
اكبر سميع الله الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل السو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليه غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولوطا اتيناه حكما
وعلما ونجيناه من القريه التي كانت تعمل
الخبائث انهم كانوا قوم
سوء فاسقين
وادخلناه في رحمتنا انه من
الصالحين ونوحا اذ نادى من قبل فاستجبنا
له فنجيناه واهله من الكرب
العظيم ونصرناه من القوم الذين ونصرناه من
القوم الذين كذبوا
باياتنا انهم كانوا قوم سء
فاغرقناهم
اجمعين وداوود وسليمان اذ يحكمان في الحرث
اذ نفشت فيه غنم
القوم وكنا لحكمهم
شاهدين
ففهمناها سليمان وكلا اتينا حكما وعلما
وسخرنا مع داوود الجبال يسبحن والطير و
كنا
فاعلين وعلمناه صنعه لبوس لكم لتحصنكم من
باسكم فهل انتم شاكرون ولسليمان الريح
عاصفه تجري بامره الى الارض التي باركنا
فيها
وكننا بكل شيء
عالمين ومن الشياطين من يغوصون له ويعملون
عملا دون ذلك وكننا لهم
حافظين وايوب اذ نادى ربه ربي وايوب اذ
نادى
ربه وايوب اذ نادى ربه اني مسني الضر وانت
ارحم
الراحمين فاستجبنا م له فكشفنا ما به من
ضر
واتيناه اهله واتيناه اهله ومثلهم معهم
رحمه من
عندنا وذكرى
للعابدين واسماعيل وادريس وذا الكفل كل من
الصابرين
وادخلنا في رحمتنا انهم من الص ين
وذنون اذ ذهب مغاضبا
فظن
وذنون اذ ذهب مغاضبا فظن ان لن نقدر عليه
فنادى فنادى في الظلمات الا لا اله الا
انت
سبحانك لا اله الا انت سبحانك اني كنت من
الظالمين فاستجبنا له ونجيناه من الغم
وكذلك ننجي
المؤمنين وزكريا اذ نادى ربه رب لا تذرني
فردا وانت خير
الوارثين فاستجبنا له فاستجبنا له ووهبنا
له يحيى واصلحنا له
زوجه
انهم كانوا يسارعون في الخيرات ويدعوننا
رغبا
ورهبا وكانوا لنا
خاشعين والتي احصنت فرجها فنفخنا فيها من
روحنا وجعلناها وبناها ايه للعالمين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان هذه
امتكم
امه واحده وانا ربكم
فاعبدون وتقطعوا بينهم امرهم
زبرا كل حزب بما لديهم
فرحون ان هذه امتكم امه واحده وانا ربكم
فاعبدون وتقطعوا بينهم امرهم كل الينا
راجعون وتقطعوا امرهم بينهم كل الينا راجع
ع فمن يعمل من الصالحات وهو مؤمن فلا
كثران لسعيه وانا له
كاتبون وحرام على قريه اهلكناها انهم لا
يرجعون حتى اذا فتحت ياجوج وماجوج وهم من
كل حدب
ينسلون اقترب الوعد الحق فاذا هي شاخصه
ابصار الذين كفروا يا
ويلنا يا ويلنا قد كنا في
غفله من هذا بل كنا
ظالمين انكم وما تعبدون من دون الله حصب
جهنم حصب جهنم انتم لها
واردون لو كان
هؤلاء
الهه ما
وردوها وكل فيها
خالدون لو كان
هؤلاء الهه ما وردوها وكل فيها
خالدون لهم فيها زفير وهم فيها لا
يسمعون ان الذين سبقت لهم من الحسنى اولئك
عنها
مبعدون لا يسمعون حسيسها وهم فيما اشتهت
انفسهم
خالدون لا يحزنهم الفزع الاكبر
وتتلقاهم
الملا
ئكه هذا يومكم الذي كنتم
توعدون يوم نطوي
السماء كطي السجل
للكتب كما بدانا اول خلق
نعيده وعدا علينا
انا كنا فاعلين ولقد كتبنا في الزبور من
بعد الذكر ان الارض يرثها عبادي
الصالحون ان في هذا لبلاغا لقوم
عابدين وما ارسلناك الا رحمه
للعالمين قل انما يوحى الي انما الهكم اله
واحد فهل انت انت م
مسلمون فان تولوا فقل
اذنتكم على
سواء وان ادري اقريب ام بعيد ما
توعدون انه يعلم الجهر من القول ويعلم ما
تكتمون وان ادري لعله فت
لكم ومتاع الى
حين قال رب احكم
بالحق وربنا
الرحمن المستعان على ما
تصفون الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
سلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين ان شاء الله
تونايت زكاه المال
‏before
we before we
there
حديث رسول
الله next
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى الله
عليه
وسلم
حسن رول الله ى الله عليه وسلم اتم الصف
الاول ثم الذي يليه فان كان نقص فليك في
الصف
[Silence]
المؤخر صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم اقيموا الصفوف وحاذوا بين المناكب
وسدوا
الخلل ولينوا بايدي اخوانكم ولا تتركوا
فروجات
للشيطان صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
عليه
وسلم رسول الله من وصل صفا وص الله ومن
قطع صفا قطعه
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله علسلم
might ح رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
طبعا احمد
يعني عمود
الاسلامه المال
‏tym
[Silence]
ر
‏ag
[Silence]
امام ابو
حنيفه الامام سعيد بن
المسيب سعيد بن
جبير امام
مجاهد حث
رسول الله صل
علس صل
عليهل you
given امام ابو حنفه رحمه
الله
second امام مك امام الشافعي امام احمد
امام
الشعبي امام
طووس امام
woman عائشه رضي الله
عنها عبد الله
عم
الله عبد الله
[Silence]
زكاه الله سبحانه
وتعالى ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وصلى الله
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين جزاكم الله
[Silence]
استووا استووا اعتدلوا
والبي سجده تلاوه ان شاء الله انذا سكن
ركعه ي سجده تلاوه انذا سكن ركعه ان شاء
الله الله اكبر
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم ان زلزله الساعه
شيء
عظيم يوم ترونها تذهل كل مرضعه عما ارضعت
وتضع كل ذات حمل حملها وترى الناس سكارى
وما هم بس
ولكن عذاب الله
شديد ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير علم
ويتبع كل شيطان
مريد كتب عليه انه من تولاه
فانه يضله ويهديه الى عذاب
السعير يا ايها الناس ان كنتم في ريب من
البعث فانا
خلقناكم فانا خلقناكم من تراب ثم من نطفه
ثم من علقه ثم من مضغه مخلقه وغير مخلقه
لنبين لكم ونقر في الارحام ما
نشاء الى اجل مسمى
ثم نخرجكم طفلا ثم لتبلغوا اشدكم ثم
لتكونوا
شيوخا ثم يخرجكم طفلا ثم لتبلغوا اشدكم ثم
شيوخا ومنكم من يتوفى
ومنكم من يرد الى ارذل العمر لكي لا يعلم
من بعد علم
شيئا وترى الارض هامده فاذا
انزلنا عليها الماء اهتزت
وربت اهتزت وربت
وانبتت من كل زوج
بهيج ذلك بان الله هو الحق وانه يحيي
الموتى وانه على كل شيء قدير
وان الساعه اتيه لا ريب فيها وان الله
يبعث من في
القبور ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير
علم ولا هدى ولا كتاب
منير ثاني عطفه ليضل عن سبيل الله له في
الدنيا خزي يذيقه يوم القيامه عذاب
الحريق ذلك بما قدمت يداك وان الله ليس
بظلام
للعبيد ومن الناس من يعبد الله على حرف
فان اطمان
به ومن الناس من يعبد الله على حرف فان
اصابه خير نط مان به وان اصابته فتنه
انقلب على وجهه خسر الدنيا
والاخره ذلك هو الخسران
المبين يدعو من دون الله ما لا يضره وما
لا
ينفعه ذلك هو الضلال
البعيد يدعوا لمن ضره اقرب من نفعه لبئس
المولى ولبئس
العشير ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار ان الله يفعل ما
يريد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
ان انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين من كان ان من كان يظن ان لن
ينصره الله في الدنيا والاخره فليمدد بسبب
الى السماء
فليمدد بسبب الى السماء ثم ليقطع فلينظر
هل يذهبن كيده ما
يغيظ وكذلك انزلناه ايات بينات وان الله
يهدي من
يريد ان الذين امنوا والذين هادوا
والصابئين والنصارى والمجوس والذين اشركوا
ان الله يفصل بينهم يوم
القيامه ان الله على كل شيء
شهيد الم تر ان الله يسجد له من في
السماوات ومن في الارض والشمس
والقمر والشمس والقمر والنجوم والجبال
والشجر
والدواب وكثير
من
الناس وكثير حق عليه
العذاب ومن يهل الله فما له من مكرم ان
الله يفعل ما
يشاء الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر هذان خصمان اختصموا في ربهم فالذين
كفروا قطعت لهم ثياب من نار يصب من فوق
رؤوسهم
الحميم يصهر به ما في بطونهم
والجلود ولهم مقامع من حديد
كلما ارادوا ان يخرجوا منها من غم اعيدوا
فيها وذوقوا عذاب
الحريق ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار يحلون فيها من اساور من ذهب
ولؤلؤا ولباسهم فيها حريق
وهدوا الى الطيب من القول وهدوا الى صراط
الحميد ان الذين كفروا ويصدون عن سبيل
الله والمسجد الحرام الذي جعلناه للناس
سواء العاكف فيه
والباد ومن يرد فيه بالحاد بظلم نذقه من
عذاب اليم
واذ بوانا لابراهيم مكان البيت الا تشرك
بي شيئا وطهر
بيتي وطهر بيتي
للطائفين والقائمين والركع
السجود واذن في الناس بالحج ياتوك رجالا
وعلى كل ضامر ياتين من كل فج عمي
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
جزاكم الله خيرا شكرا جزكم الله فتح الله
علي الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
واذن في الناس بالحج ياتوك رجالا وعلى كل
ضامر ياتين من كل فج
عميق ليشهدوا منافع لهم ويذكر اسم الله في
ايام معلومات على ما رزقهم من بهيمه
الانعام فكلوا منها واطعموا البائس
الفقير ثم ليقضوا تفثهم وليوفوا نذورهم
وليطوفوا بالبيت
العتيق ذلك ومن يعظم حرمات الله فهو خير
له عند ربه واحلت لكم الانعام الا ما يتلى
عليكم فاجتنبوا الرجس من الاوثان واجتنبوا
قول
الزور حنفاء لله غير مشركين به ومن يشرك
بالله فكانما خر من السماء فتخطفه الطير
او تهوي به الريح في مكان
سحيق ذلك ومن يعظم شعائر الله فانها من
تقوى
القلوب ذلك ومن يعظم شعائر الله فانها من
تقوى القلوب لكم فيها منافع الى اجل
مسما ثم محلها الى البيت
العتيق ولكل امه جعلنا من سكن ليذكر اسم
الله على ما رزقهم من بهيمه
الانعام فاله اله واحد فله اسلموا وبشر
المخ
الذين اذا ذكر الله وجلت قلوبهم والصابرين
على ما اصابهم والمقيم
الصلاه ومما رزقناهم
ينفقون والبدن جعلناها لكم من
شعائر الله لكم فيها
خير فاذكر اسم الله عليها صواف
فاذا وجبت جنوبها فكلوا منها واطعموا
القانع
والمعتر كذلك سخرناها لكم لعلكم
تشكرون لن ينال الله لحومها ولا
دماؤها ولكن يناله التقوى منكم كذلك سخرها
لكم لتكبروا الله على ما هداكم وبشر
المحسنين
ان الله يدافع عن الذين امنوا ان الله لا
يحب كل خوان كفور اذن للذين يقاتلون بانهم
ظلموا وان الله على نصرهم
لقدير الذين اخرجوا من ديارهم بغير حق الا
ان يقولوا ربنا
الله ولو لا دفع الله الناس بعضهم ببعض
لهدمت صوامع وبيع وصلوات ومساجد يذكر فيها
اسم الله
كثيرا ولينصرن الله من ينصره ان الله لقوي
عزيز الذين ان مكناهم في الارض اقاموا
الصلاه واتوا الزكاه وامروا بالمعروف
ونهوا عن المنكر ولله عاقبه
الامور وان يكذبوك فقد كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح
وعاد
وثمود وقوم ابراهيم وقوم
لو واصحاب مدين وكذب موسى فامليت للكافرين
ثم اخذتهم فكيف كان
نكير فكاي من قريه اهلكناها وهي ظالمه فهي
خاويه على عروشها
وبئر معطله وقصر
مشيد افلم يسيروا في الارض فتكون لهم قلوب
يعقلون بها او اذان يسمعون بها
فانها لا تعمى الابصار ولكن تعمى القلوب
التي في الصدور
ويستعجلونك بالعذاب ولن يخلف الله وعده
وان يوما عند ربك كالف سنه مما
تعدون وكاي من قريه امليت لها وهي ظالمه
ثم اخذتها والي المصير قل يا ايها الناس
انما انا لكم نذير
مبين فالذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم
مغفره ورزق كريم والذين سعوا في اياتنا
معاجزين
اولئك اصحاب
الجحيم وما ارسلنا من قبلك من رسول ولا
نبي الا اذا تمنى القى الشيطان في
امنيته فينسخ الله ما يلقي الشيطان ثم
يحكم الله اياته ان والله عليم
حكيم ليجعل ما يلقي الشيطان فتنه للذين في
قلوبهم مرض والقاسيه قلوبهم وان الظالمين
لفي شقاق
بعيد وليعلم الذين اوتوا العلم انه حق من
ربك فيؤمنوا به فتخبت له
قلوبهم وان الله لهادي الذين امنوا الى
صراط
مستقيم ولا يزال الذين كفروا في
مريه منه حتى تاتيهم الساعه
بغته حتى تاتيهم الساعه بغته او ياتيهم
عذاب يوم عقيم
الملك يومئذ لله يحكم بينهم فالذين امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات في جنات
النعيم والذين كفروا وكذبوا باياتنا
فاولئك لهم عذاب
مهين والذين هاجروا في سبيل الله ثم قتلوا
او ماتوا
ليرزقنهم الله رزقا
حسنا وان الله لهو خير
الرازقين
ليدخلنهم مدخلا يرضونه وان الله وان الله
لعليم
حليم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين ذلك ومن عاقب بمثل ما عوقب به ثم بغي
عليه
لينصرنه الله ان الله لعفو غفور ذلك بان
الله يولج الليل في الهار ويولج النهار في
الليل وان الله سميع
بصير ذلك بان الله هو الحق وان ما يدعون
من دونه هو الباطل وان الله هو العلي
الكبير الم تر ان الله انزل من السماء ماء
فتصبح الارض
خضره ان الله لطيف خبير له ما في السماوات
وما في الارض وان الله لهو الغني
الحميد الم تر ان الله سخر لكم ما في
الارض والفلك تجري في البحر
بامره ويمسك
السماء ان تقع على الارض الا باذنه
ان الله بالناس لرؤوف رحيم وهو الذي
احياكم ثم يميتكم ثم يحييكم ان
الانسان
لكفور لكل امه جعلنا من سكنهم ناسكوه فلا
ينازعنك في الامر وادع الى ربك انك لعلى
هدى مستقيم
وان جادلوك فقل الله اعلم بما
تعملون الله يحكم بينكم يوم القيامه فيما
كنتم فيه
تختلفون الم تعلم ان الله يعلم ما في
السماء
والارض ان ذلك في كتاب ان ذلك على الله
يسير ويعبدون من دون الله ما لم ينزل به
سلطانا وما ليس لهم به
علم وما للظالمين من
نصير واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات تعرف
في وجوه الذين كفروا
المنكر يكادون يسطون بالذين يتلون عليهم
اياتنا قل افان ابئ بشر من ذلكم
النار النار وعدها الله الذين كفروا وبئس
المصير يا ايها الناس ضرب مثل فاستمعوا له
ان الذين تدعون من دون الله لن يخلقوا
ذبابا ولو اجتمعوا له وان يسلبهم الذباب
شيئا لا يستنقذوه منه ضعف الطالب
والمطلوب ما قدروا الله حق قدره ان الله
لقوي
عزيز الله يصطفي من
الملائكه رسلا ومن
الناس ان الله سميع بصير يعلم ما بين
ايديهم وما خلفهم والى الله تر رجع
الامور يا ايها الذين امنوا اركعوا
واسجدوا واعبدوا ربكم واعبدوا ربكم
وافعلوا الخير لعلكم
تفلحون الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر وجاهدوا في الله حق جهاده هو اجتباكم
وما جعل عليكم في الدين من حرج مله ابيكم
ابراهيم هو سماكم المسلمين من قبل وفي هذا
ليكون الرسول عليكم شهيدا وتكونوا شهداء
على
الناس فاقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه
واعتصموا بالله هو
مولاكم فنعم المولى ونعم
النصير الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الشفع والوتر
استوه الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره
خير وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف
ابراهيم وموسى الله
ا سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا ايها الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا
فيه ملء السماوات وملء الارض وملء ما شئت
بينهما من شيء بعد احق ما قال العبد وكلنا
لك عبد اللهم لا مانع لما اعطيت ولا معطي
لما منعت ولا ينفع ذا الجد منك الجد اللهم
لك اسلمنا وبك امنا وعليك توكلنا وبك
خاصمنا وبك حاكمنا فاغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما
اخرنا وما اسررنا وما اعلنا وما انت اعلم
به منا انت المقدم وانت المؤخر ولا اله
الا
انت اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من توليت
وبارك اللهم لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك سبحانك تقضي
بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اصلح لنا ديننا الذي هو
عصمه امرنا واصلح لنا دنيانا التي فيها
معاش
واصلح لنا اخرتنا التي اليها معادنا واجعل
الحياه زياده لنا من كل خير واجعل الموت
راحه لنا من كل شر واجرنا من خزي الدنيا
وعذاب
الاخره اللهم احسن عاقبتنا في الامور كلها
اللهم احسن عاقبتنا في الامور كلها واجرنا
من خزي الدنيا وعذاب الاخره
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما
ابقيت واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على
من ظلمنا وانصر صرنا على من عادانا ولا
تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا تجعل الدنيا
اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا تجعل الى
النار مصيرنا واجعل اللهم الجنه هي دارنا
وقرارنا برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم انا نسالك الثبات في الامر
والعزيمه على الرشد الله اللهم انا نسالك
قلوبا سليمه والسنه صادقه اللهم انا نسالك
من خير ما تعلم ونعوذ بك من شر ما تعلم
ونستغفرك لما تعلم انك تعلم ما لا نعلم
انك انت الله الاعز الاكرم اللهم اعتق
رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق رقابنا اجمعين
من النار اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا وازواجنا واولادنا واصدقائنا وكل
من له فضل علينا من النار برحمتك يا عزيز
يا غفار سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وصل اللهم وسلم على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه والتابعين
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏m